we are very excited about our next guest
they're not orange they're not orange
they're here they star in the new
thriller it's called this is a great
title for this movie emily the criminal
really sums this up film is about a
young woman her name is emily she's
struggling to pay off seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debts
but what does emily do because of her
criminal record it's very hard for her
to find steady work so she decides to
take part in a very dangerous credit
card scam to make money aubry plaza
plays emily you probably recognize her
because you know the hit shows parks and
recreation remember her from that and
theo rossi he starred in the sons of
anarchy you know him plays youssef who
helps run the stolen credit card scam
this is a clip
in a few minutes you would go to the
store and buy some merchandise
any of these flat screens is okay
[Applause]
just buy one
and we looked outside
we pick up the merchandise and we pay
and that's it for today
these are stolen right the information
on them is stolen yes
i know you guys are so good aubrey plaza
and theo rozzie we were just saying you
guys are so good at this movie good
morning you guys and welcome to good
morning morning we lost the mic it's all
right
that's okay you guys look great by the
way thank you very fantastic thank you
aubrey do you know this song and aubry
was her name yes i was named after that
song really from bread not an ordinary
girl yeah not an ordinary yes i love it
that's the same same yes i love the girl
so welcome welcome welcome aubrey lyn i
want to start with you because most of
us remember you from parks and rec and
the thing that struck me about your
character then she's such a surly sour
puss face all the time i know so in this
movie to see you smile i look look aubry
knows how to smile
they told me i had to start smiling a
couple years ago
[Laughter]
so big difference between we call this a
thriller and a comedic role
yeah what attracted you to this
particular character because she starts
off as you know you think oh she's a
nice girl you're corrupting her but
she's a nice
but she's a nice girl go ahead go ahead
who's corrupting him yes
that's the real question that's the real
question uh well the script is awesome
so i think we both read it and had the
same reaction we were like these are
really good characters and yeah i love
how different it is from anything i've
ever done it's a complete you know it's
a completely different kind of role than
i've ever had and i love how complicated
she is and she's like an unapologetic
anti-hero and we don't see a lot of
those you know yeah female characters
out there and you're an executive
producer on this one too okay yeah very
much i know can you believe it yeah
movies you guys are very charming in it
and you are a character we've seen more
in movies the charming criminal uh heart
of gold uh lure her into uh greater and
greater crimes
what attracted well actually no let me
ask you the same question
part of what made this role interesting
to you is that the character is lebanese
correct and you have you are part
lebanese syrian lebanese how did you
take that background in your family and
use it to inform the role itself most
excited i've ever seen my mom about
anything
ever yeah everybody came out at woodwork
aunt maliki my buddy uh
yeah jameel everybody started calling me
uh
my uh friend muhammad mo
read the script and i listened to it all
the time just to get the dialect right
so they wanted to make sure you had the
right accent everything you know they
asked did he go to university you know
when did he come they just wanted to
know everything and get it so precise
because the representation was so
incredible were they helpful theo
unbelievably helpful how so how so just
like in the way down to like the french
influence in lebanon like of what they
say and like the food and there's a big
scene with mom and mm-hmm yeah which we
love and uh we don't want to ruin
anything yeah but it was just getting
that right so it was really nice to see
them involved because of the scientists
just the exit it's it's the layers of
the character yeah make it special
aubrey um your character gets into some
pretty intense
fighting scenes you're robbed you're
attacked how do you you look like you're
in great shape but how do you translate
but nate and she fights back big time
too big time and you cheer her on i know
this is the second movie that i've uh
maced someone so i got two under my belt
oh watch out for you
i'm really good at making people teasing
people amazing people you're also good
with a box cutter just saying a girl
[Laughter]
don't i'm not going to worry about how
many years okay i'm done i'm not no i'm
not i'm not i'm not
yeah well i didn't have to train i
didn't train but um oh just all natural
is what you're saying it's all natural
you know i grew up in wilmington
delaware okay okay she's an athlete um
and yeah i was an athlete growing up i
actually i'm very athletic i played a
lot of sports and we worked with the
stunt coordinator he was great i had a
stunt double but i did a lot of my own
stunts and a lot of my own driving
you're really good what are you saying
you're very rare what do you what we
what do you hope the message is that
people will get out of the movie
ultimately i mean because let me can i
just say i won't spoil anything but it
the ending was a total surprise to me
because i had a prediction on how it was
going to turn out it did not turn out
that way right great plot twist
um
that's all i'm going to say about that
that's all i'm going to say about that
but what do you
what do you hope the message will be
how incredible she is in it um i think
that she is incredible in it too you're
incredible thank you yeah you light up
the you light up the screen
uh yeah of grand larceny and more um
well i mean you got to do what you got
you got it who's the real criminal
really that's the real question that's
70 000
the man is the real criminal the
criminal is at the top the criminal is
at the top establishment yeah the
establishment the system
let's just say guys she really wanted to
pay off her student loan yeah a lot of
people do it's going to be a very
relatable character i got to tell you
it's a revenge yes thriller for the gig
you know millennial economy millennials
that's what you guys are awesome dirty
fairy from millennials and it's a it's a
greatly made it's a the movie is well it
just rips you crazy it's awesome acting
is incredible well done thank you so
much for joining us you guys are the
best leave the criminals it opens in
theaters on friday make sure you go see
it i promise you will not be
disappointed come